foreign ER answer is no you don't need a
college degree to get into Tech at
Amazon they never ask about you know
what's your college degree which college
do you go to what's your GPA hey
everyone so I'm just about to jump on a
call with David a principal Solutions
architect at AWS I got to meet him when
I traveled to Korea early this year for
work and I got really inspired by his
career Journey David is based in Seoul
and has been at AWS for over seven years
now after high school he made the
decision not to go to college and so in
this video we're going to be talking
about how to land a job at AWS without a
college degree let's jump right into it
hi David great to have you on the
channel today oh thank you for having me
so do you want to tell the viewers a bit
about yourself at the start of the video
I mentioned that your principal product
Solutions architect based in Seoul but
in your own words how would it describe
what you do at AWS I've joined AWS about
seven years ago and when I first joined
I joined as a level six Enterprise
Solutions architect and in my role there
I worked with some of the largest
Enterprises and media companies in the
United States and in my role I really
enjoyed working with service teams and
customers together so for example I'm
working with like the Estuary team and
maybe a networking team and connecting
Engineers together like that are working
on similar problems within Amazon to
help deliver products for customers and
in doing so I was able to transition
into a role about three or so years ago
so I work for the vice president of
engineering and my role on his team is
to really help make AWS easier to use
and working with multiple Services teams
across all of AWS to have a Better
Together experience for our customers
well sounds like a really cool role and
you know the reason we're here today is
to discuss whether or not you need a
college degree to get into Tech I
remember when we first met in Korea you
mentioned that you actually didn't come
from a college background but through
experiences you were able to gain the
skills to land a job in the cloud
industry so my question is is it
necessary to have a college degree to
get into Tech more specifically AWS yeah
for sure I mean the shorter answer is no
you don't need a college degree to get
into Tech and that was always something
that worried me because out of high
school I went directly into a role that
interested me in technology and I saw my
peers and my my brother go and he'll get
degrees and all this and I was worried
that this will kind of cause me a
problem in the future and it never did
so when I interviewed at Amazon they
never asked about you know what's your
college degree which college did you go
to what's your GPA nothing like that
they asked me questions like how would
you solve this problem or how would you
approach this design and we really value
our amazonians and our candidates to be
hungry for knowledge and just I always
tell people this to like don't accept
things for the way they are always dive
deeper and try to truly understand
something so there's a lot of valuable
material out there you can learn from
and it's just it's not gonna it's not
gonna hold you back and I would say just
you know explore your passions and if
it's in Tech you know definitely give it
a shot here hmm yeah definitely we were
talking about how there's quite a few
people in AWS that are in technical
roles who didn't come from a technical
background but the good thing is a lot
of skills are transferable between
different roles so what was your journey
into Tech like did you feel like not
having a college degree affected you in
any way yeah so my Junior Tech was I
started off with like video editing and
I had a camera and I always enjoyed like
making videos and even try to copy music
videos I saw on MTV back in the day like
how could I create someone like this and
I really enjoyed that and then I that's
I'm from San Diego I moved to Los
Angeles I got an internship in a visual
effects company up there and then went
on to working at Technicolor for nearly
10 years and I ended up as a director of
production networks at Technicolor
working on feature film post-production
and episodic TV post-production uh I
think the area that I feel a little bit
disadvantaged not having a degree is
when it comes to writing like Amazon is
a very heavily written culture so we do
you know the one pagers and six pagers
where we we have our meetings and we all
review a document in the room first and
then we discuss it and seeing my peers
do a fantastic job writing very strong
documents is an area that I need to
continue to improve so I feel maybe I
would have been stronger in that by
going to college but at the same time I
was able to immediately dive into my
passions and dive into my career and
then if anything now I'm kind of
learning on the job for um for the
document process yeah what I noticed as
well is that regardless of whether you
have a degree or not most of what you
learn is on the job anyways and there's
probably two groups of people watching
this video right now the first are those
who want to get into Cloud but don't
necessarily want to spend the next three
years in college to get a degree first
and the second group are career changes
so they have a degree already but want
to land a job in a different field to
where they studied for example in the
cloud industry both groups or people are
usually concerned that they have a
skills Gap and that not having a
relevant degree might put them at a
disadvantage so what advice do you have
for viewers who are in one of these two
situations yeah absolutely so we
regularly see all sorts of backgrounds
at Amazon so we have team members that
are product managers that came from a
legal background we have somebody who
runs infrastructure for us came from a
saddle making background so we're not
alone in either no degree or just
completely unrelated degrees and I think
what really stands out is the
willingness to learn and just really
apply themselves so we don't necessarily
care where the background is we've had
candidates also or transition industries
from like advertising industry coming
into being technologists and it's just
really across the board there so I think
to stand out even if you don't have a
degree or if you don't have even
relevant working knowledge what stands
out is when you show projects that
you've done so for example at home I'm
always measuring you know temperature
humidity CO2 air quality like a
particulate matter in the air and it's
really easy to build a dashboard like
what AWS services are using the the
create a dashboard and show how that
works it's just there's tons of projects
you can go into and get Hands-On with
AWS and just kind of showing that you're
passionate about it and learning new
things that solve problems I think that
helps you stand out so speaking of
building technical skills without a
college degree I'd like to take a moment
to introduce today's video response
brilliant if you've been watching this
channel for a while you will know that I
strongly believe that the best way to
understand technical Concepts is through
project-based learning brilliant is an
interactive platform that teaches
Hands-On lessons in maths science and
computer science they have a ton of
Great Courses for all knowledge levels
and instead of just getting you to
memorize information brilliant guides
you through fun problems that come with
step-by-step Solutions so if you're
someone looking to land a job in the
cloud industry and want to improve your
programming skills I recommend checking
out their programming with python course
you can actually get started for free by
heading to brilliant.org forward slash
Tech with Lucy and the first 200 people
will also get 20 off their annual
membership now let's get back to the
video so ultimately we're not looking
for a college degree we want people who
have maybe relevant experience or
passion in the space and if they can
show an outcome they can show like I
built these projects on AWS or I build
these projects technically and then kind
of think through bigger problems right
like have an open mind and always be
curious and hungry for more knowledge
and that's what really helps you stand
out you can find your path right like I
was a customer facing Solutions
architect I transitioned roles into the
service team
there's a ton of knowledge out there a
ton of information the Netflix Tech blog
is really good it talks about you know
designing complex systems and there's
just tons of knowledge now whether it's
on YouTube or blogs they can learn
anything out there so just you know stay
hungry be curious and you know I think
you have a good good future here great
yeah it's really interesting to hear
your perspective coming from someone who
has had an amazing career in Tech and
didn't start off with a college degree
hopefully this gives the viewers a lot
of encouragement and motivation and just
helps demystify that the only way to get
into Tech is by attending University so
as always please give this video a like
if you found it helpful and I'll see you
in the next video bye for now